today i'm going to show you the
limitations of lots why power grades are
revolutionary compared to them and how
to use davinci resolve to create your
own lots no matter if you're using
premiere pro final cut as your main
editing software to showcase the
limitations of lots in general i have
here a test slot which i will apply on
the footage
looks pretty good but the yellows look
super desaturated so let's try to bring
back the yellows and here comes a
problem when i try to bring back the
yellows i notice very little is changing
and that is because the lot desaturated
the yellows to a point of no return so
the information is gone after you
applied a lot to a clip you're actually
working against it and you're losing
control over the image
luts in general are okay but are very
limiting and can hold only so much
information to be more exact only hue
saturation and luma values so they are
very limited in what they can reproduce
from a more complex color grade
also you cannot go inside the grade and
adjust it to your liking which means
normally you have to work against a lot
and can result in colors falling apart
and frustrating experiences
that is because each editing software
has its own language so they had to
create a universal standard a file that
worked for each
that's why when i apply this slot and
try to recover information it's a
useless and frustrating battle with no
happy endings
power grades on the other hand will
offer you full control and transparency
over the adjustments and finally they
can be exported as lots for any other
software
so basically you can just use premiere
final cut as your main editing software
and use davinci as your lot creator and
i'll show you how
we'll start with how to import power
grades into davinci resolve how to
organize them into folders and finally
how to use them to create your own lots
so as an example for this tutorial i
will import my creative film power
grades which contains 35 film contrast
55 classic film colors together with the
beloved resolution effects
as you can see i already created a
couple clips with these power grades and
they look really really good
first in the color tab left corner make
a couple power grade albums by pressing
right click and choose add power grade
album
make four of them and rename them by
double clicking on the album name first
will be the note 3 second film contrast
third film color and the last will be
the halation
you can find the power grade on my
website link in description down below
go into each folder and start importing
the creative film pack one by one by
pressing right click and import with
output lut
[Music]
now that we have everything imported and
organized let me show you how to use the
creative film powergrade and how you can
make your own custom film luts
[Music]
you can start by either adding your own
nodes pressing alt s on windows or
command s on mac or by using my custom
node tree to save you some time i'll use
the already imported node tree to make
it easier let's add a contrast and
exposure to establish the base look of
the footage so you can understand
exactly what i'm doing nodes are pretty
much just like layers in photoshop and
they work sequential meaning the last
node always will have power over the
rest so if i add a final node and lower
down the saturation it will affect all
the other nodes this is a quick tip you
can enroll in my online classes if you
want to learn more tips about color
grading in a short period of time link
in description so first we set a
contrast and exposure to see what we are
working with scrub to all the film
contrast to see exactly how it will
affect the image and then choose your
favorite
to apply it just drag and drop on top of
the node we can go in the curve tab and
adjust it to your liking you're gonna do
this with regular luts which is a huge
advantage if you don't like the one
chosen and you want different film
contrast hit control z on windows or
command z on mac to reset the node to a
previous version then just choose a new
film contrast and apply it
[Music]
remember you must activate the splines
to edit the curve
[Music]
next we scroll through the classic film
color album and check a couple to see
which one would best fit our footage
again you just have to drag and drop on
top of the desired node
i'll just apply a couple to see how it
affects image until i find one that i
like
to switch between the film colors faster
i just drag and drop the film color then
hit ctrl z to reset the note 3 to
previous versions and apply a new film
color from here you either leave it as
it is or you can dive deeper into the
settings and adjust different values
i have a node explanation sheet
contained in the product folder so you
know exactly how each node affects the
image and where are the adjustments
located
as you can see there are some really
great color palettes in this collection
and it's making my life so much easier
from here you can either leave it as it
is or you can dive deeper into the
settings and adjust different values
in the film color node you can go into
different curves tabs and adjust the
colors on your taste
for example in this shot i feel like the
reds are too saturated so i will just go
into huber's saturation and bring it
down just a notch
so this is much faster and easier than
starting from scratch with a regular
grade and you have full control compared
to a classical lot
if you're using davinci you can play
around with inhalation settings and
you're pretty much done if you're a
premiere or final cut user follow the
next steps to export the lot
right click on the clip and choose
generate lut remember lust contain only
three values hue saturation and luma so
any davinci resolve plug-in effects
won't be contained by the lut so let's
disable the collision and the film grain
let's make a 65 point q blot to ensure
colors will not fall apart
choose the destination folder and export
and now you can create as many luts as
you want without even having to learn
color theory
you can also create black and white lots
just bring down the saturation to zero
and apply your favorite film contrast
this is how you can easily create your
own lots using the creative film power
grade for davinci resolve there's a link
to the power grade in the description
down below
the cool part about this power grade is
compatible with the rest of my product
let's say we have a super 8 mm home film
power grade you haven't seen the video
i'll put a link in the upright corner
for you to watch later all you have to
do is just choose a clip and double
click to apply the power grade it's that
easy
let's adjust the contrast to match the
footage and here you can see multiple
nodes all our names so it's easier to
find and know what you're working with
these power grades were made to work
with any kind of footage log rec709
10-bit or even 8-bit it's finely tuned
so colors won't fall apart
this power grade pack comes in 10
flavors and has really vibrant and
nostalgic kind of colors but even though
you have 10 different flavors maybe you
get bored and just want something new so
you can borrow a color palette from the
creative film power grades and create
something completely new go back to the
classic film color album and just drag
one of the color schemes onto the film
color node and now you have a totally
different look and this applies with all
my power grades the 35 read and film the
8 millimeter home film and the vhs
camcorder emulation which is a huge
value if you think about it
so what i'm trying to do with these
power grades is give you great color out
of the box but also give you full
control over how the image should look
like and also enable you to be more
creative
combining 35 contrast gammas together
with over 50 classic film colors your
possibilities are pretty much limitless
and can easily get over 1000 unique lot
variations and that without even
entering the notes and modifying them
so you can find all these power grades
on my website the major problem with
using luts they sometimes don't work
well with our footage because it was
shot in different scenarios with
different lightings and colors
so if the footage is a little bit
overexposed or has different colors then
you just start working against a lot to
match it with the rest of the footage
and end up spending more time repairing
something that could have been only a
couple of minutes because luts are
destructive while power grades are not
now you can take control of your image
by creating your own custom lots easily
without any compromises with power
grades you can easily edit with full
control you can actually learn about
color theory just by going inside each
node and experimenting with a good base
finally if you don't want to use davinci
you just export the desired look as lots
and you can use them in premiere pro
final cut or any other editing software
but davinci is free and has great color
grading features and the experience is
much nicer
if you want to find out more about color
grading i invite you to my online course
which will help you easily understand
color grading in a short period of time
in this course i will guide you in the
process of creating your own footage and
explain different techniques that will
make the whole process easier to grasp
all the lots will be provided at the end
of the course for free so go check it
out save your spot is going to be fun
link in description so that's it for
today hope this helped clear out some
questions let me know in the comments
what you like to see next until then
have fun and stay curious
see ya
[Music]
you